[Music]
welcome to Harvard Law School ladies
let's go around the table and report who
you are and why you're occupying a place
that could have gone to a man I am Ruth
Bader Ginsburg my husband is in the
secondary class and why are you here
mrs. Ginsburg to learn more about his
work so I can be a more patient and
understanding wife the laws has women
stay home men go to work but all people
must be treated equally you think you
can change the country we should look to
her generation they're taking to the
streets what if you got hurt or arete
mom it's a rally not a riot
don't brush she gets their stubbornness
can't imagine the discrimination on the
basis of sex is legal we need to right
this wrong
let's topple the whole damn system of
discrimination
[Music]
she thinks gender equality is a civil
right
our obstacles to our children's
aspirations if you lose who will set the
woman's moving back ten years you don't
get to tell me when to quit
get your emotions in check you first
[Music]
we've been ready for this your whole
life there is no aspect of the law at
which you can be bested the word woman
does not appear even once in the US
Constitution nor does the word freedom
your honor
[Music]